in this lecture we provide a quick
introduction into the conceptual
framework of classical statistics we use
the word classical to make the
distinction from the Bayesian framework
that we have been using so far recall
that in the Bayesian framework unknown
quantities are viewed as random
variables that have a certain prior
distribution in contrast in the
classical setting an unknown quantity is
viewed as a non random constant that
just happens to be unknown we can still
carry out estimation without assuming a
prior for the unknown quantity for
example if the unknown theta is the mean
of a certain distribution we can
generate many samples from that
distribution and form the sample mean
the weak law of large numbers then tells
us that this estimate will approach in
the limit as n increases the true value
of theta after going through this
argument we will then take the occasion
to introduce some terminology that is
often used in connection with classical
estimation methods now the sample mean
provides us a point estimate for the
unknown theta but does not tell us how
accurate that estimate is to give a
sense of the accuracy involved we
introduce the concept of a confidence
interval which is an interval that has
high probability of containing the truth
eita in general it is a common practice
to report not just estimates but also
confidence intervals but as we will
discuss one has to be careful in
interpreting what exactly a confidence
interval tells us we will see that we
can easily calculate confidence
intervals using the central limit
theorem and we will discuss in some
detail some extra steps that need to be
taken if we do not know the variance of
the random variables involved we will
then continue in the direction of
greater generality we will see that by
repeated use of various sample means
we can also estimate more complicated
quantities such as for example the
correlation coefficient between two
random variables we will conclude by
introducing a general estimation
methodology the so called maximum
likelihood estimation method this is a
method that applies always even when the
unknown parameter of interest cannot be
interpreted as an expectation it is a
universally applicable method and
fortunately has some very desirable
properties